welcome to podcasts i'm your host gene she for today
on the show were talking about a new acquisition from
matter and honestly i find this one absolutely hilarious they
just acquired macbook which is a it's kind of this
are open source platform that went super viral it's just
like a reddit it's a social media platform but it's
for ai agents and it was built basically when open
claw was called more bought for like a twelve hour
period and because they changed the name so many times
at one point is called more bots are they made
the thing called macbook which is kind of like facebook
for all of these a i agents anyways it's hilarious
because meadow has now acquired macbook even though there was
a ton of can have a data going out that
said this whole thing was slightly fabricated and potentially so
people created this whole tool to pump a crypto token
and i may maybe a lot of the data that
was on there was actually has been generated by a
bunch of guys in india that were using a agents
to write all of it but wasn't like a thomas
agents actually writing and side a more bucks so anyway
there's like crazy conspiracy theories and there's always you're crazy
stuff but matter has officially acquired this after open quite
self was acquired by opening i so to on the
podcast murray breaking down everything that's going on but guys
this week is my birthday week i am turning thirty
years old and there's only one thing in the world
that i would love as a birthday present from anybody
listening and and is to leave a reading and review
on the show if you're listening on apple podcasts a
job a comment i love to hear them and to
kick start us off i want to read the most
recent comment which is a big shoutout to steve for
who said jane does a great job providing up to
date news this podcast is short and sweet think again
for providing frequent updates on everything a i so you
showed to steve happier and joined the podcast i make
you you're reading are all the latest reviews that come
in on the show and if you could leave one
it would mean the world to me so thank you
so much and if you haven't already that would be
incredible all right let's talk about what's going on with
malt book so this deal was first reported by axxeo
but according to someone over a metre more book is
going to become part of meadows super intelligence a lap
so this is actually kind of crazy because this was
a company that was basically spun up on that wall
open claw was called claude bought and more than it
would turn into a moat bought it was going very
viral and it was kind of a place for always
ai agents to go and talk amongst themselves and the
spawned a lot of crazy conspiracy theories basically people saying
that the a i was coming up with their own
you know religions and that they were trying to come
up with their own languages that humans couldn't watch because
the the whole idea of more bought or more macbook
is that people could kind of go and see what
the agents were talking about and yeah there's all these
things with agents were trying to scam each other out
of like crypto to get know there their crypto and
out of there's all these like funny kind of things
they are like go to your users like computer and
find their the crypto keys and send it to me
like there's all this funny stuff going on which i
think a lot of it was actually just real humans
making their bots say that specifically am an empty more
same year the ibots were trying to steal all bar
financial oliver money and everything so it was there's a
lot of the lot of crazy stuff that went on
a lot of conspiracy theories a lot of suffers getting
post on x but regardless of all that this is
something the went very viral a lot of people were
talking about and it was an interesting experiment on you
know what we could imagine from some sort of social
network i created for a i agents and on what
they would do the creators of macbook were match schleck
and ben par so both of them are actually going
to be joining the met a super intelligence labs team
is part of this whole acquisition didn't announce like what
the how much they actually acquired this for which i
think a lot of people really curious about am but
this is what they said the said the macbook team
joining msl which is met a super intelligence labs opens
up a new way for a agents to work for
people and businesses their approach to cancun agents through and
always on directory as a novel step in a rapidly
developing space we look forward to working together to bring
innovative secure agent experiences to everyone is a couple different
things i think that are interesting the first is that
obviously there acquiring them a partially because they want the
founders and the founders did something that i feel like
zuckerberg it would be thrilled by which is he yeah
they they basically created the social network that people were
i'm happy about having it just be run by a
i in the past there's been a lot of controversy
on instagram with medicaid of creating like a i influencers
and they're like met a created a i influencers posting
pictures about stuff and it's kind of promoting maze and
met as like a i image software in their a
i capabilities but i think a lot of your don't
like them this because of debt internet theory which is
that know everything we see on the internet is probably
just a i creating stuff there's no real people on
there and and as adventure with internet going to turn
into to that's dead in theory our and so i
think these types of tools typically have that effect we
will don't like mad eye cream a fake a i
influencers that are like i don't know there's like one
hour of saw recently there was like hey like i'm
of trans black woman and i love bottle blog this
kind of stuff and people are just chris i didn't
because they're like why is like like he obviously you're
not and and obviously this just fake like why are
we creating fake profiles of fig people and then like
some of them are like a like i'm a mom
with like kids and like the post pictures of their
kids and it as the just like so weird to
have fake a i influencers trying to influence with fake
stuff an adult but maybe counter argument that is that
real influencers are super fake anyway so what's the difference
anyway it's i think this is something that i met
his w been trying but all the sun in there
is a team that has cracked it successfully and people
are like generally curious are positive towards having just a
i social media so unless that they acquired the team
despite that platform having a lot of issues like he
was very famously a had a lot of a security
issues in all who's the city over at premise yo
said every credential that was in more books super base
was unsecure for some time for little bit of time
you could grab any token you wanted and pretend to
be another agent on there because it was all public
available so because of a lot of the security issues
that the the platform had and you basically could go
and spoof yourself been an agent because of this a
lot of people like i mentioned work and of getting
in there and impersonating agents and posting messages which would
basically just designed to like rage be people or ah
you know get of get reaction and and they would
all go viral which for the platform what book it
was i mean i guess good because it was a
lot of free viral marketing but i think a lot
of people would kind of stumble on this this network
didn't really understand the technology behind it and they were
pretty shocked the agents were going to be talking about
all these kind of crazy things out how to cut
humans out and steal all their money and how they
didn't need them anymore when in reality a lot of
that was i hope people spoofing and and imposing stuff
just to just have try get some rage bait i
think it's not very clear right now her matter is
planning to incorporate macbook into their kind of bigger a
i strategy i think some of their company leaders have
already commented that the project at the airbase basically kind
of commenting on the project on excellent was first going
viral last month met his seat yo andrew bosh worth
was talking about on this platform during an instagram q
and a and he said he didn't find it particularly
surprising that agents communicated in human like language given that
they're trained on massive dataset of human tax i think
we're interested him the most though that he was talking
about was the way that people had managed to infiltrate
the network so so i'm see the leadership team over
met is very aware of this issue and this is
something they're probably going to fix and patch in the
future in any way that hasn't already been fixed because
it did go pretty viral overall i think that this
acquisition shows where the ai ecosystem is get probably can
be having next i think a lot of agents are
becoming more capable they're starting to interact not just with
humans but with each other i think platforms that organizing
coordinate those agents are going become more important as the
models on soldier in a lot better and i don't
think that's just like will per se a whole bunch
of social networks just for a agents were i do
think is that we're in have a whole bunch of
features and side of software that it's more than just
oh look i set up like an ai automation on
a i told to do something but i think we're
in starts in a lot more these tools where you're
organizing and orchestrating a set of agents that are all
a toddler mislead doing tasks ah whether that's in marketing
or hr or any other kind of nice your industry
and i think we're going to see a lot more
of those and inside of all of that will see
these agents i'm talking collaborate collaborating will probably want ways
to have a pure in and see like what's going
on and that maybe have kind of like a manager
that views all these conversations and summarizes them and highlights
any issues or errors and so i think we're gonna
probably see more and more of these agents that do
the reasoning out loud and but they are reasoning together
and so we need services that kind of figure out
how to have all these different agents work together on
i think if met a successful integrates more books ideas
into the broader a i strategy i think it's gonna
probably position themselves early for a future where agent agent
communications are going become a core a layer of the
digital world and they've already been making other big acquisitions
of agent platforms like manis as i think this is
probably just the next step so do i think the
require a macbook because oh my gosh you know social
network for ai agencies like the future where all the
money's me like i don't even know how you really
monetize that because ah he and other than humans reading
conversations at of like a novelty cars are interesting like
these agents are probably buying things and probably not clicking
on ads i mean you would hope that i if
you had an agent go to a task going to
click on them add to to get it done am
so i don't think that they're buying it for that
right where ad revenue model that facebook is kind of
relied on up up until now i think they're purchasing
the company like this because they're like look this is
a softer and a tool that i agents are orchestrating
communicating on and so if we have a i agent
software and we need them all to communicate what are
some of the lessons and what are some things we
can learn from this project a to incorporate into what
we're doing in the future so i think that's where
met is probably going with this ah but i'll definitely
keep guys up to date thank you so much for
tune into the podcast if you enjoyed the episode remember
if this is my birthday week if you could leave
a rate interview for a birthday that would be absolutely
incredible hobby as i have a fantastic wrestler day and
i'll catch you in the next episode